[Música]
e aí eu estou louco em seu namorado ou
namorada o primeiro link a descrição do
vídeo aplicá-la ea ser a ceste e meus
próximos shows são em suzano salvador
joão pessoa
bastou ao lado do miami você vai ver com
as informações agora dois segundos à sua
frente e quem quiser ver pausa o chamado
treino no filme também fui deixando
deixando na internet assistir novamente
como é chamado é igual acontece um
negócio lá e sete dias depois a pessoa
morre tipo chikungunya atende ao que
acontece todo mundo morre porque é burro
hoje tem lugar para assistir fita mas se
você assistir uma fita que você quer
morrer e exige vídeo cassete existe mas
só raro as pessoas têm vídeo cassete com
a mesma pessoa que tem tech mix e as
pessoas têm que fixou as mesmas pessoas
que têm chevette encher o pé e acaba até
fogo fumaça echeverry um velho mostrando
chave para que eles saíssem do uso de
material de construção chapéu da nelore
estarão no chevette com abuso de camila
de polícia todos tivessem acompanhado do
velho é o vec é do chevette o chevette
tudo veio acordo com a cet tem duas
pessoas naquelas lojas de eletrônicos da
loja de eletrônicos e vai deixá-la para
consertar sua televisão no dia ela não
volta mas tem um cara olha as coisas
velhas mas não vou pra esse vídeo
cassete aqui aí tem uma mulher que chega
do lar escola mas o japão neste vídeo
cassete e vibração local não vai ficar
aquela conversa de café sou eu estava
olhando meu amigo 926 lado de fora
estava pensando olhando pra ele é meu o
meu deus estava olhando eu estava acima
do oitavo lugar neste vídeo cassete
br/cin não é roubado não mais bombástica
aguarda pelo que é meu dom da loja época
ainda assim este vídeo cassete é de uma
família cujo filho morreu há dois anos
aí eu já não comprava morreu
deixa falar as coisas do mundo é a
pessoa que pode interromper um prazer de
comprar a cogent amor que daí eu já
analisava o atividade paranormal as
pessoas morreram na casa annabelle era
da mulher que morreu não sei que dia
invocação do mal a casa era do próprio
demônio eu vou comprar um vídeo cassete
de uma família cujo filho morreu há dois
anos atrás nunca pilotei no mundo quem
faça eu comprei vídeo cassete não tem
nem perigo e ainda falou cujo na frase
cujo filho morreu amigo gil fala cujo e
se for verdade o cara fala que é de uma
família curso o filho morreu há dois
anos até hoje o rapaz o vídeo da fé só
eu é notória comprar o ipad cuja família
o filho morreu há dois anos cara é o
vídeo cassete captado o cara vai inserta
porque o povo gosta de acordar o
capítulo ela lá tranqüilos anos na dela
ele vai consertar o vídeo cassete cara
sabe acontece de estar consertando ele a
sua fita dentro do vídeo cassete hoje a
família o filho morreu há dois anos ele
tirar feita de dentro e fora da pista
que assume assista o meu deus o ser
humano é tão fácil de matar no qual o
chocolate em cima da mesa escrita se me
come a pessoa corre acho que botar a
bomba embaixo da morte de cachorro
botacini pizzi ainda tem um imbecil que
pisa também fazer isso eu tiro uma fita
de dentro do vídeo cassete de uma
família cujo filho morreu há dois anos
até a semi assistiu de telco quebra e
jogou fora a palavra canalha alguém pai
vai assistir a perda cujo filho
izan ela fecha fita ea samara liga para
ela somada a essa marca que ele ia
chamar essa maioria por ele passam
nessa hora de instalar nos carrega nessa
hora ela não está desligado nesta quarta
o capeta vem ele me bota na tomada para
carregar mas que se tiver mau contato
com a pessoa fica segurando assim ó
porta cena aparece duas pessoas
transando atrasando assim na cara para
um filme muito 26 começa com cara num
avião com medo de morrer depois a
convite do café da família cujo filho
morreu há dois anos peço que não fez
transando o menino foi para a faculdade
nem descartar a trança da faculdade é
negócio errado é avião é ver café quando
meus dez anos depois já é transando foi
a faculdade quem vai à faculdade ea
mulher dele começa a estranhar que ele
está há cinco dias sem falar com ela ela
começa a estranhar que ele está há cinco
dias sem falar com ela acho que tem algo
de errado e no brasil no tênis não é
mandar mensagens a minha namorada é um
adorno para responder já com sim
[Música]
aquela bola pega o carro e vai embora
possa se dar veneno em gasolina que
estava na cintura de gasolina em pego o
carro
ela foi foi na casa do cara não tinha
ninguém foi na universidade do cairo não
tinha ninguém ela vai no assalto à
liberdade tem uma galera assisti à fita
galera se assista a uma mulher que botar
ela assiste a fitas só que ela não sabe
se tem da menina no caso da fita que
botar ela assistiu à fita o que já está
com seis dias que a mulher assistiu à
fita mulher da universidade há 16 dias
já vai fazer um set ela dois votará
namorado para assistir à fita mas não
quero no ranking juvenil não sei pode
ser pornô como que chávez no seu cast
aqui pra mim favor me ajuda a não ser
cancelar haidar 7 dia ponta que pagar 7
dia começa com os cortes que dão
sustento no cinema fez um alerta à
margem da televisão todas é bom ou da
moeda que o negócio respeito escorrendo
a seringa se no chão
a lei fala que poço fundo mesmo metros
petróleo e cézanne moça que moças ficam
muito grande com a polícia ela sai da
televisão começam a andar com armou para
trás assim a cabeça virando se igual
sempre falei que o mundo pode consumir
menos é o que eu falei não eu acho que
se eu visse a ação mas ainda prega o
máximo que eu ia fazer isso aqui
deixa eu voltar a sonhar de chamariz
armadas podem fazer amor fazer amor
fazer amor amaral chamará osmara
[Música]
ao que ela diz kobra descobre que a
mulher estava tentando botar ela para
assistir porque quando você bota outra
pessoa para assistir à fita você se
livrar da culpa então você não morre só
que vai estudar outra pessoa olha o que
acontece como já passaram muito tempo
não tem mais onde assiste cita a galera
passa por pedras
toda vez da marca 2017 já decidi
assistir à fifa que lavar picape e
assistiu à fita pessoas na sexta-feira
ela começa a ligação da linha passou
para sete dias e ela começa a ensinar
como é saber quanto existe entendeu ela
estava dirigindo e passou um pato bateu
no vidro para assistir a um filme no
cinema
assim todo mundo leva um susto e grita e
eu pago e grita mais compacto tinha
batido no vidro ela foi olhar não tinha
passa nenhum 4 caminhão mattel era só
uma visão aquela paz ela vai copiar
posto em dry passar por outra pessoa pra
ver se ela não morre a outra pessoa
morre quando ela vai copiar desse
arquivo não pode ser copiado tomou não
cojo toma honra voltar a ficar perto da
família cujos moradores não a equipe de
la plata campeão então o moço na estrada
que o caminhante ela caminhantes que não
pode abrir um guarda-chuva onde filme a
cor que mais me assustou até agora com
um guarda-chuva briga é cada subestimar
cada susto antes ficava eles vão nos
cemitérios procurar o tubo da samarco
esse povo gosta ou não gosta de assistir
o paciente morreu e é por isso que o
povo tomar no curso eles estão abrindo o
tubo não tem muito dinheiro e fazer uma
boa cena no escuro em um monstro se
aproximando do fim de ano só uma visão
boa aí sozinha e ele sai o que ela faz
ela sai também vai lá na igreja de noite
rezar não vai procurar nenhuma ela vai
na igreja acho uma portinha congelada
porque ela entre tim e uma corrente um
negócio que descobre que ela volta para
casa e conversa com a mulher mulheres
que o padre que molestava
ela vai à casa do pai e requer o padre o
cara que abriu o guarda chuva que deu
susto nela a briga com o pai ela bota lá
o vídeo para reproduzir no céu lá cara e
o cara ficar assistindo padre ea sua
massa dizendo celular 3d muita
tecnologia estarei respeitar o mapa
mulher estava
casa do padre na parede para política
não tinha isso chega aí é o filme isso
se apagaram surgindo apagadinha mesma
tarde
se você gostou deste vídeo já fábio ao
clicar em gostei aqui no youtube não
esquece porraaaaa gostei
o meu irmão quem veio pelo facebook
volta na postagem deste vídeo e clicar
em curtir esta marca seu amigo pra ele
ver é o chamado aqui através de mim esse
amigo tem medo de assistir no cinema que
me assiste em casa assistir porque é
engraçado é legal você vê o twitter está
assistindo pelo twitter da ip em baixo
para mais pessoas assistirem brt e aqui
com minhas redes sociais aqui do lado
pode seguir no instagram você que não me
segue após fotos bem legais salvá lá
segui lá tem muitas coisas valeu é nóis
é jeca